i have a sense that there's some
kind of once we understand consciousness
better we'll understand that there's
some kind of continuum
and it would be a greater appreciation
and we'll probably understand
just like you said it'd be unfortunate
if it's the trick
we'll probably definitely understand
that love is indeed a trick
that will play on each other uh that we
humans are
we convince ourselves we're conscious
but we're really um
you know us and trees and dolphins are
all the same kind of costumes can i try
to cheer you up a little bit with a
philosophical thought here about the
last part
yes let's do it you know you might say
okay yeah love is just a
collaboration enabler and then you'll
and then maybe you can go and get
depressed about that but i i think that
would be the wrong conclusion actually
you know like i know that the only
reason i enjoy food
is because my genes hacked me and
they don't want me to starve to death
not because they care about
me it's consciously enjoying succulent
delights
of pistachio ice cream but they just
they just want me to make copies of them
the whole thing so in a sense the whole
the whole enjoyment of food is also a
scam
like this but does that mean i shouldn't
take pleasure in this pistachio ice
cream
i love pistachio ice cream and i can
tell you i
have i know this is an experimental fact
i enjoy pistachio ice cream
every bit as much even though i
scientifically know exactly
why what kind of scam this was your
genes
really appreciate that you like the
pistachio ice cream well but i my mind
appreciates it too you know and
i have a conscious experience right now
ultimately all of my brain
is also just something the genes built
to copy themselves but so what
you know i'm grateful that yeah thanks
jeans for doing this but you know
now it's my brain that's in charge here
and i'm gonna enjoy my conscious
experience thank you very much
and not just pistachio ice cream but
also the love i
i feel for my amazing wife and
all the other delights of being
conscious
you